je vous présente ma femme connaître vous
avez épousé un écu alain tu as épousé
une petite paysanne sens ce sont deux
sports
j'ai eu une idée remarquable
vous pourriez écrit pour moi les
histoires que l'on m'avait raconté mes
années d'écolière oui ce serait mon
nouveau rôle
j'aime apple claudine pas du tout
l'auteur ni ni c'est à dire de supporter
ces personnalités en fait on du cou et
des couvertures
je me suis rendu pense que par rapport à
l'environnement et au contexte
historique dans lequel elle était elle a
quand même su gérer et montrer une
personnalité féminine très contrastées
le col était un personnage avec des
facettes extraordinaire
extraordinairement variées très
nombreuses et que là on a vu une facette
de colette
mais je pense qu'on pourrait faire 100
films sur colette qui serait
complètement différent et complètement
passionnant tous autant qu'ils seraient
jab x continue probablement joliment
répand déjà parvenu à faire de vous sont
maigres
si tous ces trophées minin plus de
piquant mois d'hiver ku
c'est le plus grand succès que nous
ayons connue à ce jour une femme très
moderne très moderne
individualiste pas forcément pour la pas
forcément féministe mais pour moi très
moderne
c'est très intéressant pour pouvoir
regarder ensuite par les cris comment se
rendre compte de quelle personne c'était
et à quelle époque qu'elle vivait et
quelle vision de la vie elle avait ces
jeunes filles vous leur avez donné une
voix quelqu'un vous l'a dit et n'est-il
de l'apprendre par d'autres vous
rencontrez m'a suffi réalisation les
images étaient très belles mais j'ai
trouvé quand même que ça forçait un
petit peu certains aspects certains
stéréotypes
j'ai trouvé qu'il était sain acronis mai
et que c'était il ya des longueurs mais
bon moi oui j'ai été un peu déçu le
nouveau claudine pourquoi ne pas le
publier sous nos deux noms c'est hors de
question j'ai vu mon nom sur la rom non
nous tenons quelque chose d'explosif
si la situation nous échappe nous
risquons de sombrer tous les deux
écrivez c'est un grand personnage à la
personnages de la littérature et en tant
que femme
ni écrivaine ça fait toujours plaisir de
qu'elles soient mises à l'honneur c'est
la main qui tient la plume qui écrit
l'histoire